last night hollywood's richest and most
famous lechers assailants and enablers
gathered at the Golden Globes as their
city industry and reputations smoldered
and ruin to lecture the rest of America
on morality and demand even more
millions of dollars to play pretend we
will analyze the tone-deaf oblivious
preening then we'll dissect Stephen
Miller's showdown with former journalist
Jake Tapper in a documentary segment I
call Jake Tapper mean-girl finally daily
wires Alicia Kraus and Ariel Davidson
from the Federalist during the panel of
deplorable z-- to discuss Oprah 2020 the
deportation of 200,000 Salvadorans
200,000 Salvadorans by the way is the
new 50 million Frenchmen they can't be
wrong but they can be deported and the
psychiatric smears against our stable
genius president i'm michael knowles and
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
I did it I did it so that you don't have
to folks I was 100% of the television
audience last night for the Golden
Globes and this was really awful I
usually have to cover this stuff for The
Daily wire the Andrew Klavan show or
something this was the worst most
insufferable award show that I have ever
seen it was last night you would expect
after a year of Hollywood being ripped
to shreds all of them being exposed as
enabling corrupt corrosive sexually
deviant monsters and hypocrites you'd
expect they might be a little repentant
they might be a little penitent and you
know sorry Mia culpa keep their mouth
shut
absolutely not what they did what they
did was so brave last night
they wore I don't know if you saw there
was a why we wear black that was the
hashtag these people are so brave they
wore black clothing to a black-tie event
that's a round of applause such it
brings a tear to my eye when I think
they wore black to a formal event in the
evening it's just unbelievable
or they didn't even really apologize
they just they wore black well done
everybody
it was so so brave it was really
disingenuous to there were all of these
speeches and all of the the red carpet
and everything but it all came off as
disingenuous even Reese Witherspoon
introduced Oprah Winfrey she was winning
a big prize a big o honorary award and
the whole performance was very
saccharine it was and it wasn't
believable you would think that the best
and most famous actors in the world
would be believable at an industry event
but they weren't ironically there were
these terrible performances I think the
reason for that is they they gave up
their glamor they gave up their claims
to glamour the only reason people watch
these award shows is for the glitz and
the glamour and they're wearing a
gazillion dollars of jewelry and gold
and and dresses and things like that but
they gave that away and this has been
going on for decades but it's gotten a
much worse in the last ten years now
they just complain they just whine and
complain and it takes all the glamour
out of it here's Natalie Portman ruining
Guillermo del Toro's first the best
director went after 25 years in the
industry
and the Award for Best Director and here
are the all-male nominees
here in the all-male nominees just
totally sucked the air out of the moment
it would have been a glitzy really nice
moment why were no female directors
nominated why were they know why that
that's well here's the reason because
very few women directed top grossing
films last year or the year before
there's one example of a really good
film last year won Best Picture Lady
Bird but she didn't get a nomination
Greta Gerwig for directing it but this
happened to Ben Affleck it happened in
2012 Argo got Best Picture at the Oscars
he didn't get a nomination for Best
Director that sort of happens why are
there so few women directors I don't
know only 7% of major films were
directed by women in 2016 I think it was
like 11% last year why is that well
until recently many many more men than
women attended film school particularly
in the field of directing that trend is
still true at many film schools it is
now there's a little bit more gender
parity in film school graduates although
in the field of directing not so and we
don't really know the numbers of
applicants we have every reason to
believe that many many more people are
applying to be directors who are men
than women what why is that well we why
would we expect gender parity in every
profession there are plenty of
professions where we don't have gender
parity we don't say 50% of NASCAR
drivers aren't women this is example of
collusion or collusion of discrimination
I got in trouble on Twitter last night I
pointed this out that this random
statistic is not in itself evidence of
discrimination you would have to show
that and I got all these angry tweets
this one actress Evan Rachel Wood says
that her name Evan Rachel Wood who's on
a West world she tweeted at me very
angrily and we had a respectful
conversation she couldn't answer the
points that I was making so she said
well I'm finished with this conversation
and I said okay and then she blocked me
because they can't engage with ideas
here it's all posturing
it's all virtue signaling there is no
actual actually looking at the industry
and the statistics it's just little
lapel buttons and let's wear black and
look at how virtuous we are that and now
what we have to get to a little bit more
of this but before we go on with the
gold
speaking of luxury speaking of once
glamour and once luxury let's talk about
helix sleep
this is bringing luxury and glamour back
there are a ton of online mattress
retailers popping up these days all with
a one-size-fits-all solution to a better
sleep guess what one size does not fit
all so he looks off for something that
doesn't exist anywhere else
it's a mattress personalized to your
unique preferences and sleeping style
that will not set you back thousands of
dollars I've moved around a lot from New
York Connecticut Los Angeles it's very
tough to go in and you shop and they rip
you off at these brick-and-mortar stores
if you go to helix sleep comm slash
Noel's ko wles you take their simple two
to three minutes sleep quiz they will
build a custom mattress that will be the
best thing that you've ever slept on I
will not spend four minutes doing
anything in my entire life this is only
two to three minutes to take their sleep
quiz it's very worth it for couples they
will even personalize each side of the
mattress so as you know I prefer to
sleep on sort of a firmer mattress and
my fiance sweet little ELISA prefers to
sleep on a mattress that I am NOT
sleeping on those are just different
preferences and sleeping preferences
they will customize it to each of you
everyone from GQ to Cosmo to the New
York Times are talking about helix once
you try it out you will know why your
custom mattress arrives direct your door
in a week and shipping is completely
free there is no risk here just do it
sleep is very important you're gonna
spend a third of your life sleeping if
you're a normal person I spend about two
thirds sleeping I really want to make
sure I get my extra cuff F a beauty
sleep so try it for 100 nights if you
don't love it they will pick it up and
refund you in full go to helix sleep
comm slash Knolls KO wles
like Beyonce right now you will get $50
towards your custom mattress no risk at
all if you don't like it they'll take it
right back
helix sleep calm / Knowles for 50
dollars off your order
helix sleep calm / Knowles now into
these golden globes because that so
that's the one aspect of it there there
was all this virtue signaling on the
issue of sexism and discrimination but
then in my conversation with that
actress Evan Rachel Wood she was
complaining that
she doesn't make as much money as her
co-stars on her television show she
didn't give us any statistics presumably
Anthony Hopkins is going to make more
money than she does he's one of the
legendary actors over the last century
but regardless she complains that she's
not making enough money and yada yada
yada this actress is worth eight million
dollars according to a simple google
search all of these people who are in
this room at the Golden Globes are worth
millions and millions of dollars if not
billions of dollars like Oprah Winfrey
so to have them get up there and
complain that they're not making enough
millions of dollars to pretend and play
at pretending all day long that doesn't
play in Peoria
nobody wants to watch that nobody has
the right to direct a movie no one has
the right to direct a 50 million dollar
feature film or to act or to screen
right you don't have the right to have
movies made just because you want to and
you feel very special you have to go in
if you don't think you're making enough
money negotiate fire your agent and get
a better negotiator so that you can get
a better deal nobody's watching this
because you don't the American people
don't have to watch this we don't have
to watch you get up and shriek and
scream and yell that you're not making
enough money we can just tune out that's
what most Americans did the Golden
Globes ratings fell again even from last
year so it's down five percent overall
and a whopping 11 percent in the key
demographic of adults aged 18 to 49 this
is a six-year low it matches even as far
back as 2012 results so keep it up folks
take everybody for granted take your box
office for granted take your audience
for granted
keep on politicizing once light-hearted
entertainment it worked so so well for
ESPN didn't that's that even still a
channel anymore I don't know let's get
into the Miller interviews there's this
big famous interview over the weekend it
may got a lot of play White House aide
Stephen Miller went on the television
program a former journalist Jake Tapper
this is a segment that I will call Jake
Tapper mean-girl Stephen take it away I
can only tell you my experience which is
that I joined the campaign in January of
16 but before the first ballot was cast
and helped you get that job see now
Corey Lewandowski is the one you
offering me the job in the Trump
campaign but just to finish Bannon
wasn't abandoned wasn't helping you
Bannon didn't help you get that job on
the campaign I think the person who
probably helped me most get the job on
the campaign was probably Cory but the
most important thing because I've been
working with cord before I joined to try
and help out with the campaign so it
starts out and Jake Tapper just keeps
pushing just keeps pushing a fact that
obviously isn't true so he's trying to
tie Stephen Miller to Bannon he's saying
Betty Bannon got you the job then in
this let's not forget Stephen Miller was
on the campaign before Steve Bannon
thought he predates him on the campaign
now could you say does he know Steve
Bannon did they work together did yeah I
suppose so you could just as easily say
Stephen Miller got Steve ban in his job
when he came on the campaign these
people are all working together but
tappers got this agenda and the the tone
that comes out from this interview
Stephen Miller comes off like a robot
you know he is just there he's stating
the facts as he sees them he's
correcting some errors the several
errors that Jake Tapper is pushing but
Jake Tapper just comes off as like this
glib little schoolgirl like a catty
little school prison well don't you
didn't you do that don't you he says no
I didn't use it okay I get moves on
let's move on to his next accusation did
you write a letter outlining reasons to
fire Comey and list the rush
investigation is that true here's the
problem with what you're saying the
final draft of the letter the one that
was I'm not talking about that one I'm
talking about one that has that many if
you want to have an answer to your
question and not to get hysterical then
I'll answer it the file a draft of the
letter has the same line about the fact
that there is a Trump Russia
investigation that this has nothing to
do with so it was just moved from the
top to the bottom no he said no we look
at the letter it's the beginning the the
investigation is referenced in the
beginning of the final letter that was
released like the huge embarrassment you
had when you've got the Comey testimony
wrong issue unless Steven Steven we're
not want to talk about me we can't talk
about me at all Jake Tapper has just
gotten two major facts completely wrong
and he's been insisting on them and
insisting on them throughout this
interview well you took out then you
took
the Russia line we didn't take out the
Russia line will you moved its placement
no we didn't the Russia line is still at
the top of the memo
well I and then Stephen Miller points
that he says you know Jake you keep
getting things wrong here and you're
keep you keep trying to push a narrative
and it's a little weird buddy and all of
a sudden Jake Tapper cuts him off that's
the thing you get out of this interviews
Jake Tapper doesn't want his answers he
doesn't want to hear anything from him
he wants to cut him off and push a
narrative Stephen Miller points this out
and this I think is the central takeaway
from the interview all these so-called
political geniuses in Washington whether
it be at the big lobbying firms or in
the last week is the president because
happens to be a true statement okay it's
self-made billionaire who revolutionize
reality TV and reserves the court is
happy that you said that but no no you
might be condescending and it's been
kind of sending I'm can wait he's been
in you can be conscious that was a snide
remark you're sure he's watching and
he's happy let me tell you something why
is there a network you can look you can
be as condescending as you want it's
part of your MO but listen the you can
have 24 cent I have no idea why your
exam you whine man stupid I'm not being
condescending I'm not being
passive-aggressive how many how many
times has anyone ever said I'm not being
passive-aggressive when they when they
weren't being very very
passive-aggressive this is this is what
is really sad about Jake Tapper
he used to especially during the Obama
years he was a pretty tough journalist
played it straight when a lot of the
media were fawning over Barack Obama he
didn't do that he just played it as a
kind of straight faced guy going for the
facts and now he's this whiny shallow
petulant little schoolgirl who says well
I'm sure your boss saw it and he just
saw what you said then oh he'll be so
happy about that but anyway moving on
like are you kidding me buddy that
you're supposed to be the last newsman
in America why are you getting these
snide little barbs in this smug smarm
you don't need to do that and by the way
Stephen Miller is is a robot you can get
very unemotional answers out of him but
Jake Tapper himself can't refrain from
being emotional in this interview that's
why Miller says stop being hysterical
why are you trying to make this
personal why are you trying to get
little barbs and insults and I'm giving
you an answer Jake Tapper revisits this
later in the interview there's one
viewer that you care about right now and
you're being obsequious now being a fat
guy owed him in order to please him
Republicans to resign two aspects of
this one he has to cut him off because
Stephen Miller isn't saying what he
wants him to say so he isn't going along
with the pre scripted interview that
Jake Tapper clearly had outlined in his
head so he has to just cut him off very
rudely it was really awful even from the
beginning to bring up those personal
insults and Barb's is so rude so
unbecoming of a serious newsman but Jake
Tapper hasn't been a serious newsman for
a very long time but to get that same
exact Barban again it was pathetic I
mean it was the sort of insult that you
would hear in middle school you would
hear somebody say well I know that
really secretly you only care about this
it's not even psychobabble
psychobabble is much more elevated than
what Jake Tapper is doing here to
Stephen Miller and the and that's where
it really takes a turn because Jake
Tapper having once been a journalist he
is now fully at CNM he's doing the CNN
thing God knows why his bosses may have
told him that he had to turn up the
smarm and the smug he's basically
auditioning to be Jon Stewart outside of
this interview here are some other
examples apparently does not like any
questions about any of this not a ban
okay but I could have sworn I heard
somebody in the Trump administration
using the term ban before was it
possibly president Trump okay but to be
fair that was Sean Spicer on Sunday
surely he has not used the term ban
since then such as I don't know last
night when he spoke at George Washington
University it's all sarcasm it's a
dripping and sarcasm and he's he's so
regularly missing his role if he the
role that he once served as of being a
journalist and a straight journalist
everything now is so elitist and so
condescending as Stephen Miller I wonder
if he had that
even loaded up and ready to go to accuse
him of being condescending the Trump
administration is very good at branding
people finding an essential flaw in
their character and pulling it to the
forefront and showing that to people
that is Jake Tapper's Donald Trump I
think has made the guy go completely mad
and he can't help he wears his hatred
and fury and madness at Donald Trump on
his sleeve it's affected a lot of his
coverage regularly he just misses the
point entirely
of new stories Akbar god is great
sometimes I said under the most
beautiful of circumstances and too often
we hear of it being said at moments like
this that's the story right Jake the
story is an Allah ho Akbar the chant of
jihad is when they are about to blow
things up that that's all sometimes it's
said in beautiful circumstances that's
the story of course not it's posturing
and it's preening and other times though
he'll just outright lie it's not normal
to for a president to make fun of
disabled people right that's not normal
Yeah right
correct when did he make fun of disabled
people when did he make fun of
somebody's disability it didn't happen
this was a regular attack from the left
during the 2016 primary debates because
there was some reporter who was saying
mean things about Trump and he pretended
to be [ __ ] when he was impersonating
him but Donald Trump did precisely the
same impersonation when he was making
fun of a general when he was making fun
of Ted Cruz when he was making fun of
himself actually he was making fun of
something that he himself had done in
the past he said oh yeah I don't I don't
know I you know I wasn't being coherent
or making sense this was a total lie
Jake Tapper
honestly peddled it how about some more
I want to ask you in Quebec City last
week a white right-wing terrorist opened
fire on a mosque a mosque filled with
innocent men women and children six
people were killed President Trump has
not said or tweeted one public word
about this you want to talk about
ignoring terrorism why hasn't the
president offered his sympathy to our
neighbors in the north gee Jake do you
still beat your wife
that is a fairer question than what you
just brought up to Kelly and Conway not
only is it a ridiculous in the position
and the defense that it puts the the
interviewee in but it's just not
grounded in any reality we are know that
President Trump had already called the
the leaders of Canada and offered his
support and offered his condolences on
the phone so it isn't read did very he
publicly offered his support to the
neighbors to the north but that didn't
go with the narrative so at Jake Tapper
he had to just he had to reinvent
history and reinvent the presidency
which he keeps trying to do he tried to
reinvent it with Stephen Miller Miller
wouldn't play along so we kicked him off
of his show now so he used to be a
journalist in the Obama days it's really
gone downhill yeah during the campaign
certainly during the administration
he's even admitted his naked partisan
advocacy on television on elective
action election that hates that we
really need that Hillary Clinton really
needs to maintain let's just put this
down on the board we need to make Hilary
Clinton needs to keep a pencil we need
it we needed to catch that did you catch
what he said he didn't say the Clinton
campaign you said well we really need a
homina homina homina I mean the Clinton
campaign and so the only way that we
will ever get into the oval Omaha oh
yeah is that hot in here is it hot new
CNN studios give me a break but he said
it himself he said we are upping the
team we are working for Hillary Clinton
which was no surprise to anyone who's
ever watched CNN but it was a little bit
sad for people who used to like Jake
Tapper because he used to be a
journalist that the language has
continued since he's been since
President Trump was inaugurated and
people accuse president Trump accusing
reckless rhetoric extremist rhetoric how
about the extremist rhetoric from Jake
Tapper where President Trump's tweets
are windows into his soul unfiltered and
often seemingly unmoored unmoored and by
the way this is the perennial attack
against Republicans particularly against
Republican presidents and presidential
candidates they have to be crazy they're
all out of their minds they're all
mentally unfit to be President we're
seeing this now this is coming back up
against President Trump we'll talk about
it a little more later some of its
history with Ronald Reagan and Barry
Goldwater and even Dan Quayle even
George W Bush but he doesn't just stop
there he doesn't just question
president's mental capacities he also
questions his loyalties even the darkest
days of the Obama White House's war
against FoxNews the Obama White House
never banned Fox from attending any sort
of press-gang goal or briefing this
White House does not seem to respect the
idea of accountability this White House
does not seem to value an independent
press there is a word for that line of
thinking the word is unamerican that
isn't true by the way Barack Obama did
try to disinvite Fox News from a press
gaggle I think in 2009 and it was only
because the rest of the press wouldn't
show up they were so offended by it that
they had to continue to invite them but
Obama actually did try to do that
nothing unprecedented at all how about
the final hit Jake if you are a soldier
in harm's way right now if you are a
hungry child in Appalachia or the inner
city if you were an unemployed worker in
a hollow shell of a steel town that's
not a president who seemed rather
focused on your particular needs and
wants
that's a president focused on his bad
press it was unhinged a lot of Americans
are gonna watch that press conference
and think that guy is not focused on me
I don't even know what he's focused on
just the fact CNN just the facts I'm
Jake Tapper I'm a real journalist look
it looks like he was giving a campaign
speech looks like he himself was running
for president what is it about
journalists who say you know listen I
don't know any of these people and I'm
certainly not in their shoes but if I
were one of these wonderful Americans I
would hate this president I would hate
President Trump and you should too
totally totally pathetic and you know he
once said - he said no one has called
people who don't want Isis to move to
their neighborhood Islamophobic that has
never happened in the history of the
world it's all of this hysterical
dishonest word choice that Jake Tapper
has been engaging and it's glib its
snarky it's that cattiness it reduced
him from a real journalist to a caddie
high school girl really pathetic and I
hope he turns it around some of us hope
for that but trump derangement syndrome
hits us all and seems to have hit in him
speaking of the fairer sex let's bring
on our panel we have Ariel David
some from the Federalists we have Alicia
crass The Daily wires own ladies thank
you for being here I've been looking at
Jake Tapper for like 15 minutes it's
very nice to look at you and hear from
you Alicia who won the debate between
tapper and Miller I don't think it was a
debate and I have to say I'm gonna go
against you here Michael having been in
radio for a very long time and you know
TV and podcasting for a fairly long time
12 minutes Jake Tapper gave Steve Miller
12 minutes and it took seven and a half
minutes before tapper actually hit back
and was annoyed with him so I was
getting annoyed just watching it and I
think that Steve Miller definitely was
dodging indefinitely was playing to what
he thought that the President of the
United States wanted to hear and did not
answer one of those questions at all I
mean Jake tempura asked a basic question
about when do you come to the campaign
and then he started talking about how
anything that's a question of when did
you come to the campaign he made an
accusation he said Bannon brought you on
the campaign and Miller said on the
campaign before banner okay all that to
say bad performance by both guys can we
agree there I don't think it's this
takedown of the mainstream media that
everyone is claiming it is it was
obviously Stephen Miller winning time he
was given more than 12 minutes to I mean
12 minutes of Jake Tapper interrupting
him
I do like totally agree with you he went
in there with his agenda as do all White
House flacks they go in there with their
bullet points that they're gonna hit
Stephen Miller is a robot he's a highly
intelligent robot and he was going to
hit his points he wasn't going to answer
certain of Jake Tapper's questions but
that doesn't excuse Tapper tapper had
two premises that were just flat-out
false then he kept hammering and my
question I don't care about that and
I've called them faults and then moved
along he tried to but Jake kept
interrupting he kept interrupting him he
did say that was false the Russia line
was in the top of the thing but I don't
even really mind that I don't care if
Jake Tapper's gonna hit a White House
aide pretty hard I suppose that's his
job my question is the glibness the
snark do you think that in this media
age of this cliquey clickbait the age
where so much of politics is now
entertainment do we need that or is
there a place for a journalist like Jake
Tapper circa 2009 who can cut all of
that out and just be really bearable
but just stick with the facts I think
that there's definitely a place for that
but I think unfortunately you're going
to have a very few people proven by your
monologue that I think would triumph
that I think that you some people out
there only want to hear what they want
to hear for their side and their guy and
I mean hey it's a free market
I love the First Amendment it gives us
the ability for you to have your opinion
have your opinion me to have mine and
Jake Tapper and Steve Miller to have
theirs as well I think that I personally
would love it there's very few
journalists out there that I actually
think are unbiased everyone of course
has biases and certain networks show
that in different ways I think that
there's a part of the audience that
would like unbiased reporting but even
when Jake Tapper has done unbiased
reporting when it comes to the Trump
white house even when Jake Tapper hit
Hillary Clinton in 2016 during the
campaign it still wasn't enough for some
people and I don't know that any of
these people can win and that's a very
good point the decay of Jake Tapper in
some ways I don't even really blame him
for it's sort of a decay of political
journalism and he's a big leading figure
and he's gone where his bosses probably
wanted him to go but still to quote a
great man
sad aerial is Steven Miller a good
public face for this administration we
were talking about a very intelligent
robot who came in and kept just was guns
a-blazing against Jake Tapper should
they keep sending him out as a public
flack well it's interesting because when
he did that press conference on
immigration I actually think he did a
phenomenal job I think he did a great
job of addressing Acosta's advances in a
lot of ways and I think he ended up
coming out of that as sort of the hero
against fake news media now you know
this interview I agree with Alicia it
was just it was bad on both sides I
think student Miller's bassy sort of
look disengaged from it for majority of
it and I felt like tapper just handled
himself pretty unprofessionally and I
was surprised because I usually have a
higher opinion of tapper especially when
it comes to CNN in general I think
usually I mean he's the greatest
journalist in the history of the world
compared to his colleagues at CNN right
of course but I think that this
interview in particular I was pretty
disappointed by both of them I would be
willing to give
Stephen Miller another chance but I
think that this interview kind of fell
short for me so I agree with Alicia
definitely it was just I mean I totally
agree Ariel I I had to watch old footage
of Stephen Miller because I know he's
capable of being better on television
and answering direct questions I mean
the Jim the Jim Acosta Steve Miller
exchange of that press conference that
Ariel just mentioned is peak Miller
doing very good thing when he corrects
Acosta's quote from the poem on the
Statue of Liberty and then brings it
back to his talking point he was just
all over the place here and if I had to
be sitting down with him trying to get
questions out of him whether I agreed
with his stance and in the White House's
positioning on the Bandon thing or not I
would have been annoyed after 12 and a
half minutes of him yappin absolutely
and as Ronald Reagan said if you were
explaining you're losing I think that's
what Miller was thinking going into this
the mainstream media have been trying to
set the agenda of public discourse
around some stupid and irrelevant
meeting that may or may not have taken
place or may or may not have included
certain figures from the campaign with
some Russian lawyer who I guess was sent
there to disrupt things and blah blah
blah blah blah and they want that to be
the new cycle every single day Stephen
Miller went in there and said absolutely
not he's responding to allegations made
in this tabloid book by Michael Wolfe
and and also Trump has just had a very
public break from his former strategist
Steve Bannon so there are a lot of
different narratives and a lot of
different news agendas they're fighting
for primacy here I agree Stephen Miller
has come off better in other venues but
again he was going in there guns blazing
on the central question of the book
itself Ariel is this book the fire and
fury by Michael Wolfe is it worth
reading have you read it Alicia have you
read it no just excerpts so you wouldn't
recommend it you don't think you think
it's just probably mostly here there's
tabloid trash
I mean it's hearsay if you want to talk
about media bias talk about NBC's Katy
tur talking to Woolf earlier and she
ended the interview by telling him
congratulations on your book being a
best-seller and congratulations on
perturbing the president I mean it's
almost a direct quote I mean to his
credit at least Jake Tapper went after
one of his colleagues the host of
reliable sources over the way
again because he said you know let's
let's take this what it is having you
know some of these things being true and
feeling like it kind of sounds like
things we've heard out the White House
isn't actually factual information and
and I think that I mean I've had friends
Bethany Mandel who's been a guest on
your show she and her husband read it
over the weekend and she said it reads
like a gossipy novel yeah and and I mean
if we're really going on the words of
Steve Bannon who we know to be a
fantastic liar then I would say 99.9%
the book is false plus Michael Wolfe
admits in the preface I too haven't
wasted my money on this I know a lot of
people on the right haven't done it
Sebastien Gorka has a great piece today
out where he says I'm not gonna spend
anything but I will read the excerpts
that are already out in the beginning of
the book the author Michael Wolfe says I
can't really defend any of this as being
true or any of the facts being true but
they are notionally true
no show I'm not quite sure that is the
best euphemism of 2018 we've already got
her if there was fake news there were
alternate effects now we have notionally
true which I think just means not true I
think you can take that you know lay out
of it and this is not true so I won't
read it either the excerpts you know
they're scintillating I sometimes read
magazines from the grocery store and but
those are a little bit cheaper than this
this work of fiction okay we have a lot
more to talk about we have beyond gossip
to talk about now but unfortunately
folks if you were on Facebook and
YouTube I have to say goodbye to you
right now if you're out the Daily wire
calm thank you so much you keep the
lights on you keep qoph fa and mic up
it's a really good way to start the year
what do you get it's ten dollars a month
or $100 for an annual membership you get
me you get the under Clavin show you get
the Ben Shapiro show you get to watch a
conversation and ask questions hosted by
our very own Alicia Krauss with me and
ban Andrew and you yes okay I'll bring
it's going away folks
now the leftist tears aren't going away
the leftist tears are gonna be pouring
and pouring and pouring this is a nice
tap or vintage I had some some of my
panel today might disagree but I've been
laughing I'm up all weekend and
especially after the Golden Globes there
were floods in my own City right now of
Los Angeles but the leftist here's
tumblr is going away you will not know
the time or the hour when it disappear
but make sure you get yours right now
you can only get it with an annual
membership to the Daily wire go to Daley
wire.com right now we'll be right back
[Music]
200,000 Salvadorans stand to be deported
from the United States they were brought
here in 2001 under a program called
temporary protected status after an
earthquake in their country now 200
thousand of them stand to be deported
Alicia is this a good idea bad ideas
that's a good priority for the
administration to stand firm on
immigration or is it going to be a PR
nightmare I think it's already a PR
nightmare because you just fell into the
MSM trap there and read the headline
what it is though is that those 200,000
people do have an opportunity to change
their immigration status and update
their paperwork and then they have the
they can stay here in addition to that I
believe it was actually too awful
earthquakes that were back to back in
2001 and it was a deal that the El
Salvadorian government made with the
United States government that let kind
of like a refugee status for at least
200,000 el Salvadorians to be here it's
been 15 years I mean that is that is a
long time I mean if long time to work
out your remember is a long time to work
out your immigration status that is a
long time to get a job to get a home to
acclimate to American society so I would
think that these people would be willing
and want to do whatever it would take to
stay here and I think in the long run
this will end up dwindling off I think
it's gonna look bad on the White House
just the way that the media covers it
but I guarantee you it'll be end up
being a very small percentage of those
200,000 that end up getting deported
well this is the issue because the
headline is 200,000 people get deported
now the secondary thought is huh they've
had had a long time to figure out their
status in the United States haven't they
they probably still have a little bit of
time yeah nevertheless that will never
be reported honestly and there were
these two big pillars of the
conservative movement for years and
years there was one that was strong on
immigration and we need to secure the
border and jobs here and stop importing
Democrats who are going to make us lose
elections the other was open borders and
there was a big wing of the party that
wanted more trade more open borders the
more libertarian strain Ariel does that
still exist in the conservative
coalition or are we now firmly a stop
importing Democrats to
I guess lose elections party well I
think there's you know if the
Conservative Party in terms of
immigration sort of waffles and I think
it depends if you tend to lean more on
the neoconservative side or whether
they're one of the Ted Cruz conservative
I think that's where I usually mentally
draw the line when it comes to
immigration you know Ted Cruz tends to
be a pretty strong immigration Hawk and
then you have other parts of the party
that tend to be a little bit more
favorable towards coming up with a
solution that might may or may not
involve amnesty for illegal immigrants
that are already residing in the United
States so I think when it comes to
addressing immigration I think
definitely the conservatives are
probably more strict on the border but
when it comes to the variety or the
disparity of opinions and then the
conservative party we definitely have a
entire spectrum I will say though with
the advent of Trump assuming the
presidency I definitely think I've seen
appreciatively a more rightward shift on
immigration and being a little bit more
hawkish on it and I I'm I tend to fall
more in that camp so I was I'm glad to
see trunk be more firm in that stance
but you know up until that point I think
the conservative party's been pretty
lukewarm on immigration and definitely
not as hawkish as they sort of put
themselves forward to be ironic you just
you bring in a lifelong Democrat from
Queens a reality TV star and you're
absolutely right he has made the
Republican Party and the conservative
coalition more conservative he's moved
us to the right I think that's just the
whimsy of God okay we have to move on
because we need to talk about our next
reality TV star president are you with
her ladies 2020 are you with her she
gave a rousing speech last night at the
Golden Globes
during which she pretended that she
hadn't been friends with rapists like
Harvey Weinstein for decades that she
and myriad other Hollywood elites
haven't covered up the heinous crimes of
Gomorrah by the C Hollywood California
many are now speculating she will run
for president she is worshipped like a
cult figure by the way coast to coast
Alicia is Oprah the next president of
the United States only if the rock does
not run against her which I am team Rock
2020 or 2020
I don't know whatever I will vote for
the drunk over Oprah Winfrey you know I
don't I I'm like about the person not
the party but if he comes out and he's
like small-government and charming as I
think he is then I'm all about the rock
Matt Walsh actually has a great op-ed of
course up on The Daily where right now
that brought up the points that you just
said you know Oprah Winfrey has been
paddling around and BFFs with Harvey
Weinstein for years and you have to
wonder when the when she has made
billions being the pulse of American
culture and entertainment and even
politics I mean look at what she did for
Barack Obama during the primary against
Hillary Clinton back in 2008 that you
know rocketed him to fame and really
gave him a huge boost when he was
running against Hillary Clinton and
people were like who is this guy
she gave him a platform you don't think
that she knew you don't think that she
heard rumors you don't think that she
had any idea about stuff that was
happening behind the scenes in the
entertainment industry I don't buy it
absolutely right and she has a lot of
other baggage - so she's worshipped like
a cult figure she's beloved in some ways
very often the next president is the
antithesis of his predecessor she had
you know George W Bush comes in after
Clinton and you know Clinton was an
unsavory undignified sexual creep and
George W Bush is going to restore
dignity to the White House born-again
Christian Clinton was this young liberal
whippersnapper in reaction to the old
stodgy Republican George HW Bush then
obviously we had Barack Obama a totally
new generation basically a younger man
he's a first black president he is much
more articulate than george w bush
george w bush could very frequently not
put two sentences together barack obama
gives rousing beautiful speeches he has
a wonderful way with words and his books
then we have donald trump and antithesis
to Barack Obama
Oprah Winfrey has that on the on the
surface Donald Trump is a villainous
figure he's always angry and firing
people
Oprah is hugging people and giving away
cars he's an old white man she's an old
black woman she they're both reality TV
they're both cultural figures she's got
this weird romantic life where she's got
I guess sort of a girlfriend and so
a fake husband and I've never really
looked too far into this but it is a
little strange allegedly a little
everything's alleged everything is
alleged but it's all pretty weird with
all of that we don't know a ton about
Oprah's personal life we do know she
worked herself up from nothing now she's
one of the most powerful people in the
world could she be Trump Ariel me okay
um you know I I don't know I think she
actually might would have a good chance
the only thing I will say is if the
economy keeps performing the way it is
performing that will be definitive
through her Trump in 2020 but I think
when it comes to Oprah's curbside appeal
I think you hit the nail on the head she
has the perfect personality for it when
it comes to purse you know policy
expertise Trump's gonna be coming into
this race with four years of her
presidency on your table for three years
and so he's gonna be able to bring that
to the table so all you know it's gonna
be funny they're playing commentators
who made this point yesterday evening
where they said it's gonna be really
interesting your watch I think Ben
Shapiro said this really interesting to
watch the media I do a total 180 on the
necessity of their already doing just so
friends and that's it you know people
are gonna be they're gonna be ready to
get behind her and the funny thing will
be is Trump will actually be more
experienced in Oprah by the time so
that's gonna be a very funny conundrum
and you know given Trump's performance
when it comes to the war on Isis when it
comes to the economy those are all gonna
be big wins for Trump on tax reform so
he'll be able to bring those to the
table so you know there are a lot of
people who's saying this would be a slam
dunk for Oprah and I I don't know why I
question that a bit just because Trump's
can we bring you know he's gonna you
know follow as well he's gonna be
bringing a pretty strong three years to
the table but Oprah he could offer us
all of that in the great economy and
foreign policy seriousness but Oprah
could give us a free car and this is
bread and circuses folks 2018 decadent
culture bread and circuses so last
question we only have a couple minutes
left we've got to talk about our stable
genius president we have to talk about
that stable genius Donald Trump so his
response to all of the basically
baseless accusations in Michael Wolf's
tabloid fire and fury he has responded
and said that he is
quote like very smart and that he is a
very stable genius
he's not an unstable idiot which they
say about every Republican president
they do this about all of them either
they're evil or idiots and then in
retrospect they stopped being idiots but
they said about every single one and
they pretend that every Democrat
president is a genius
so Trump idiot Bush idiot bush senior
incompetent Ronald Reagan idiot Gerald
Ford idiot
Gerald for the most athletic president
they portrayed him is stumbling all over
his own feet but the Democrats Bill
Clinton oh what a genius even Jimmy
Carter utterly feckless president well
he's a physicist he's an engineer he's a
genius right you see this again and
again Barack Obama genius we have no
evidence of that but that's what they
say
with all of that Donald Trump is the
first president to smack back and say no
I'm a very stable genius two questions
you can give both of your answers Alicia
is he a very stable genius and was that
response a good one no to the first
question and secondly if Donald Trump
hadn't been so open and honest about how
he does not drink alcohol and why he
does not drink alcohol I would have
thought that he was drunk tweeting so
he's not only he's not a very stable
genius he has shaky hands no alcohol
absolutely right
ariel is he a stable genius and was it a
good idea my mom always says to me if
you have to say it it's less likely that
it's true so nobody has to tell you
they're stable of genius then chances
are you know it's less likely that
that's the case so I'll leave it at that
but we're talking about politics do you
remember Bill Clinton ball politicians
have to repeat things ad nauseam that's
all they do they memorize like six lines
and they smack you over the head with
them Bill Clinton and that and in his
reelection campaign he said we got to
build a bridge to the 21st century
bridge to the 21st century I was like
six years old at the time I can't get
that out of my head it's still ringing
around my head he said it so many times
in this case Scott Adams the Dilbert guy
had an immediate reaction he said what
Donald Trump is gonna do with his weird
diction his weird word choice and crazy
behavior unstable behavior he's gonna
make all of his own critics
a tie his name to the word unto the word
staple genius for the next two weeks
yeah has he done that I think he has
yeah I think that I mean they're a title
he's a genius he's a staple genius cuff
it all these words he's invented so many
because he's a great brand marketer so
he's attached words to all of his
opponents but even cough FA he just made
that word up whole cloth that's like the
thesis of my show I'm gonna write my
political dissertation on the word cough
fa well it'd be blank vanity I already
wrote my political dissertation very
good point ladies so good to have you we
have Intel Isha crass from The Daily
wire Ariel Davidson from the Federalist
well I was so nice via that are just so
much Jake Tapper and Natalie Portman as
I am I went and then those ladies came
in and made me feel so much better that
is our show today
come back tomorrow we're gonna do it all
again I am Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
Hague
supervising producer Mathis clever our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jessa alvera the Michael nul show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017